as of late night King has his own dragon
and since dragons are huge game changers
in battlefield the living will have to
figure out a way of killing the undead
bazarian dragons are powerful extremely
difficult to kill their scales and
Heights are incredibly tough and wrong
when grown they resist arrows swords and
fire Vizier has been erected into a
white Walker which grants him even more
protection the eyes are where Jagan is
most vulnerable the eyes and the brain
behind him in the novel Steven says that
dragon cannot be killed through the
underbelly since scales there are just
as tough as those along dragons back and
flanks then the gullet is not an option
as well to explain all the possible ways
of is Aaron's death which will surely
occur at some point of the final season
let's take a look at how dragons have
been taken down throughout the history
of Westeros the most of the Targaryen
dragons were killed in the dance of
dragons which took place roughly 107
years before the events of game grumps
it was a civil war between the Targaryen
fighting for the Iron Throne
the most common way the Dragons have
deities at the claws and the teeth of
either dragons there were 20 dragons
alive at the beginning of the Civil War
and only three survived surely after the
Civil War de gens went extinct it was
the only major world that had dragons
fighting on both sides and we have now
again with two dragons fighting for the
living and one for the dead lazarey on
the 19th dragon and smallest of the
three dragons will have to face his
larger and stronger siblings in the
final season and this is not coming as a
huge surprise however as ever since
nothing resurrected vissarion it became
quite certain that the final season will
contain some epic fights between the
dragons many fans seem to like a theory
with dragon kills bazarian which could
have been for share of the in a very
first season with Aaron his name that
her demeanors his brother Viserys and
joggin on the other hand is named after
Danis late husband cult rock back in
first season wizards threatened a knee
which resulted with Drago killing him by
dumping molten gold onto his head it's
quite a popular theory that Drago named
that reserves will get his own version
of the golden crown in the last season
by the dragon named a tree Kolchak Jon
killing Azaria would be poetic but
vissarion's not whites and therefore
fire cannot kill him according to the
showrunners Aaron's a nice dragon
not just to reanimated corpse and thus
cannot be destroyed by fire let me
explain in season seven Missourians
killed and then raised back to life by
the night King this led to an online
debate among the fans about what exactly
undead Viserion is some claimed him
don't simply be a white dragon like all
the other corpses brought back to life
something like the undead white horses
the others on the other hand claimed
that Vizier has been turned into a
dragon version of
it would be a vivid sky referred to as
Aryan as an icon and said that he was
shooting blasts of freezing ice breath
out of his mouth instead of fire making
the fans even more confused however due
to the season 7 finale being submitted
for an Emmy nomination the script was
made publicly available in August 2018
clarifying a few points but also raising
more questions and contradictions the
script director refers to his errand as
a nice try on the script gives
description when the night King appears
at the end that is done the same thing
to with Aryan that he did to Kresser
sons only those were babies and this is
a dragon so according to the TV writers
reasons now a dragon version of a vibe
poker the script also specifies that his
breathing blue colored fire not eyes
blasts making HBO view versus Geis
statement false even though the script
finally confirmed to us that is airing
the vibe Walker rather than the white it
also raises several issues the script
says that the net King's done the same
thing to be there and that he did to
cress her son's only those were babies
and this is a dragon this is not correct
the night king did not do the same thing
to Vizier he did to cress her son's eyes
area most clearly they then had to be
resurrected in contrast cress her son
explicitly needed to be delivered live
to be turned into White Walkers the
script her first vision is a nice dragon
but this is not for the nice dragon
heads a nice dragon is a legendary
creature somewhat resembling a dragon
but made out of living guys these
mythological creatures of legend in the
world of Westeros breathe blasts of
freezing cold in contrast to how normal
dragons breathe out fire they're called
breath can instantly freeze people and
think solid a mirror opposite of how
breath of regular dragons burned them as
Aryan is not made out of living guys
he's a flesh and blood on that creature
he's bringing blue fire instead of cold
which is why bazarian is not a nice
dragon
long story short with Aryans not white
he's a white Walker and fire cannot kill
him Danish dragons cannot kill him
wizard can be killed by two things and
two things only dragon glass similar in
steel share dragon could rip out his
throat but what would that do to the end
a dragon
Vizier no longer needs to breathe or
blood to stay alive the only thing that
his dragons could do is to dismember him
so that he's unable to fly and move so
that someone could pierce civilians
still sword or dragon glass dagger to
resign however that might not be as easy
as it sounds
even though this area is a small stud of
the tree he may have just become the
strongest out of the three after he was
resurrected his strength and power had
been increased misery has been turned
into white Walker meaning that his
siblings superior size and numbers may
not be enough to slow him down
so
to kill this area so call it easiest way
would be to kill the man who resurrected
him the night King as seen in the
previous season when Jean killed a white
Walker with Longclaw killing of Eibach
results with the instant collapse of the
servants they erased not a [ __ ] night
King would result with the final death
of his Aryan as well as with the
collapse of his entire army since he
created all the white walkers who then
created old White's
let's put it this way you kill the night
King all the white walkers die and if
all white walkers die all the whites
collapse as well because they have been
created by either white walkers or their
leader since going night King would end
the long night I don't see him dying
before his dragon the living might
eventually defeat the night king but
it's highly unlikely that this Jagan
will die this way early Stan before the
very bitter end
next out of a very few possible ways to
kill the Syrian will be with Qyburn
scorpion in blue team battle the power
cable scorpion was shown of inflicting a
flesh wound on its target Jurgen took a
serious hit in the shoulder forcing him
to land carried Pierce's eye instead of
his shoulder it were punctured his brain
and jorgen would have died the sister
wife of Aegon the conquerer a nice
Targaryen luster dragon in precisely
this manner during the conflict with the
Dornish with Sharon could be killed it a
very lucky shot from scorpion bowl that
would pierce his eye and driving to his
brain but only if the normal head of the
bolt is replaced with dragon glass or
Valyrian steel another way to kill
Viserion will be with a magical weapon
that has something to do with words in
the books it's hinted that the living
side might be able to use some sort of
magical weapon to kill the night Kings
dragon there's a possibility that the
living could use one more weapon to kill
this area just as the night king use his
magical weapon to kill a dragon the
living might use their own magical
weapon to kill the night Kings dragon
the weapon in question are very rude
arrows the skin comes from the events
that happened during Aegon's conquest
back then torn Stark the king who
kneeled that her witnessing most of the
kingdom's south of the next submitting
one by one to Aegon turn decided to a
mess his army in march south to meet
Targaryen warlord on the battlefield
after singing of dragons and his massive
hosts I realized that the war was
already lost instead of fighting he
chose to bend a knee and surrender his
crown in order to save his people while
some of the northern Lords did agree
with this someone near him only to find
and die against the Targaryen sinner
dragons but it was thorns best her
brother Brandon's known that had another
idea Brandon offered to cross the
Trident along at night to sneak into the
Targaryen camp and assassinate dragons
during judge that this was impossible
and that the failed attempt would only
invite additional retaliation from
Targaryens so he chose to instead send
Brandon and three masters across the
river to negotiate a gun
Surrender how did this best brother of
the king who kneeled imagine this heroic
quest to succeed charging the three
dragons to the sword surely would not do
the job the hint comes from brains vivid
visions in the novels in a dance with
dragons brain stark has several visions
of the past through Winterfell Skaar
tree one of these visions is of a pale
fierce and dark eyed young man who
slices three branches of the weirwood
and shaves them into arrows it has been
theorized that this may be Brandon Snow
preparing arrows to kill the three
dragons of Aegon the conquerer arrows
from real roots were already used to
kill a dragon daemon Blackfyre and Sons
were also cut down by our arrows fired
from the root boughs at the command of
Lord Brien and rivers the man who would
later become the three-eyed raven for
some reason we repeatedly being told
that vir roots are able to slay dragons
even though one might say that those
arrows would not work on the knight
Kings Dragon I think it's just the
opposite it would work on this area and
just as or even better than dragon glass
or Valyrian steel given the origin of
the knight King and White Walkers the
White Walkers are made by the children
of the forest would show their powers
from the V roots some theorists believe
that a piece of that power could kill
the nine Kings dragon with one shot for
this to come true brain will have to see
the same vision he'd seen the books that
Reynolds no preparing weirwood arrows to
kill dragons and figure out that it is
if it truly is one of the very few
possible ways to kill the night Kings
dragon I believe that if this comes true
brain will figure it out in the heat of
battle between the living and the dead
it will be of the crucial points from
bran to share this information with the
most skilled archers among the ranks
having varied arrows made for the entire
army would be quite a job to do not to
mention that there are very few V routes
so who would we branch champion in this
task would Brenna point this essential
role to his sibling Jon Snow or perhaps
herb Ronald Blackwater whose skill has
already been proven and shown off
multiple times the best choice to beat
Theon Greyjoy accomplished Archer whose
confidence will surely be restored after
completing such a task of a huge
importance really inside thean skill
with the longbow has been pointed out
multiple times and since has done
nothing with it to this date he might
just use it in the final season perhaps
this has been foreshadowed back in the
first season
run the iron island sigil mccracken its
words with you're not so lords the
Greyjoy's veins for their skills at
archery navigation and lovemaking and
failed rebellions schedule a stag a
crown
in conclusion among the very few
possible ways of killing the knockings
dragon I place my bet on Qyburn scorpion
dragon list or a leader and still
pointed bolts how I would like bazarian
to die would be an epic battle between
all three dragons and their riders Danny
riding DRA gone along with Justin riding
ray got the drago named after his father
fighting a knight king and his dad a
dragon to the bitter end
bazarian kills jog on Danny barely
rights reserved in all saloons regal but
file Vizier and injures Regal John
swings a leg over his saddle and leaps
from his dragon to the knight Kings just
like Prince daemon targaryen did during
the dance of dragons well in Damon's
hand was dark sister House Targaryen
Valyrian steel swords John has his own
Valyrian steel sword Lanka opens Damon
fought his nephew Prince Aegon John snow
will fight the night king it will end
exactly the same just like Damon did Jan
will also kill his opponent but this
time opponents Regan will not strike the
lake it will collapse all the dragons
will die denied King and his army will
be defeated and Justin will be severely
injured but he will thrive it's even
rumored that Damon stride the fall as
well and lived a quiet life out of sight
with his lover this would be my take on
how I'd like to see it happening based
on no evidence er hints to sported
compared to previous possible ways of
killing with area madder than some
history and lore that would repeat
although it's something George are more
intense the